M it's
God it's
God how you doing pretty good you Muslim
oh yeah I am all right awesome all right
so you saw the sign y I Saw the Sign
prove that Jesus is a Muslim for 2200 so
how would you start this well that will
first of all what's cute approve for you
um I need the earliest you know uh
information that we have on Jesus what
he believed what he taught how he
practiced his religion stuff like that
that'll tell me if he believed in Islam
or not if I believe in Islam No Jesus if
Jesus believed in Islam yes oh funny
thing do you know that Jesus was in his
Earth 2024 years ago 2,000 years ago
okay so when did his lamb came to the
world 600 years after Jesus after Jesus
right yes do you need a birth
certificate or something no I don't I I
think other Muslims do though
yeah cuz look other Muslims say that
Jesus is a Muslim right they say Jesus
is a Muslim but I'm like how is that
possible when Islam didn't come until
600 years after him but they insist that
he was a Muslim they put it on their daa
tents they say look we love Jesus he was
a Muslim just like us just like Muhammed
just like Abraham and we're just as
Christians we're like okay prove it you
know so that's why I'm offering the
money okay what is Muslim you tell me
I'll go with it whatever however you
define it I'll go with it someone that
believes in God that's the only requ to
be a Muslim believe in God he's the
almighty he's the only one and every
single other human being that work his
Earth was just a me human being okay so
your definition of being a Muslim is
just believing in God yes okay so my
question is do JY you you're Muslim you
believe in jins and Angels right yeah
okay do jins believe in God yeah they do
are jy's Muslim yeah they do J are
Muslim yeah they are the ones who cause
chaos on the earth and deceive Mankind
and stuff demons mus yeah right okay so
let me ask you this um if I demons yeah
if I believe in God no nobody nobody
interrupt so I believe in God right yeah
um but I believe that the God that I
serve the almighty the all powerful is a
statue that I have in my closet am I a
Muslim the statue that in the closet is
that statue like who made that statue I
did you did made that statue yeah but I
believe it's God and created everything
God and he did not check any
psychiatrist like any mental problems no
I didn't I didn't get checked in the
hospital yet well that's not God God is
Almighty he's only one I can made a
statue right about you you Christian yes
and you believe in God yes you believe
he's unique he's only one so but let's
pause there cuz you you're making some
good points so your your point was is
that the statute is not God it's not the
true God right so I can't just believe
in anything a statue too right right
anybody can make a statute so the
statute is not the true God right so I
can't say that I'm a Muslim while also
and say that I believe in God by calling
a statute my God I'm not a Muslim even
though I believe in God I don't believe
in the right God not the true God I
believe in a false god an idol the true
God I mean Allah is God Allah means
translation of God right so so there's
not multiple God that's the only one God
you called him God I called him Allah
yeah so what I'm getting at is that
Allah has a specific identity and
qualities that make him who he isly
right and so a statute is not what he is
so if I say I believe in God but I'm
calling God the statute I'm crazy but am
I a
Muslim no exactly so what I'm saying is
that believing in God is not enough to
be a Muslim you have to believe in Allah
specifically of the Quran make sense
doesn't make sense it doesn't no
so all right so if if that doesn't makes
sense then I can then I can believe in a
statue call it God and I be a Muslim cuz
I believe in God by your definition
right my definition is God is only one
Statue can be multiplied right yes or no
Y how can God be only one and we have
100 code God but see what you're doing
no keep the mic on him cuz I got my own
mic so the but the point is is that all
you're doing is you're just you know now
you're going just against my Theology of
a being God but you're not going against
the definition that you gave of being a
Muslim according to your defin look
according to your definition I can
believe in a false god and be a
Muslim that's my definition that's what
you heard because all you said is a
Muslim is one who believes in God so if
I say I believe in God but the God I'm
talking about is a statute I'm a Muslim
okay let's re translate okay who made
that statute I did he did make
that yeah wait a second God is Almighty
let's just Now call him Almighty do no
let's keep it at god let's keep it at
God no you making statute God okay let's
all right let's say I call him statute
Almighty now how can he be you can kick
his ass you can BR his
ass right yeah so look all you're
showing me is that is you're You're just
showing me how my theology doesn't make
sense but you're not showing me how I
don't fit the definition of a mus I'm
just saying God is Almighty he's only
one whoever believe in God actually he's
a servant of God all right so C let me
just see that so if I say that God is a
statute am I a Muslim no all right if I
say that God is a tree am I a Muslim no
if I say that God is a mother am I a
Muslim n if I say that God is a father
am I a Muslim nope all right okay there
we go so now we know what you mean by
God he's none of these things he doesn't
be nor is begotten no companions he's
only one in his as he by himself right
not a father not a mother doesn't sleep
doesn't eat none of that stuff okay so
this is what I need I need you to show
me that Jesus believed and submitted to
this God that we just
described
really now you want like proof that
Jesus believes in God believes in the
god that you just described who's not a
mother or a father has no children who
doesn't have any companions right that
concept of God I need to see that Jesus
believed in that what you're doing is
really dangerous you know why why
because you want because it destroys his
l no no no he wants me to deny the
Trinity the God the Father the Son right
I don't want you I want you to accept
that I want you to accept that you want
me to prove it otherwise right prove
what he want me to prove me otherwise
that's what you said prove me that
Jesus Jesus believe in the god you said
it's not father right right right right
so you want me to disprove your belief
right not disprove my belief that's
dangerous if I was violent I would take
it aggressively why disa because like I
told you you
trying to like make me destroy your
belief no no I don't want you to
necessar destroy look let me tell about
me I I care about trth if it's true that
Jesus is a Muslim I have to submit to it
okay if there's evidence that Jesus is a
Muslim I have to believe that and and
you know why I started a conversation
with bu's proof because my proof is not
your proof that's why proof is proof
regardless of how I feel or you feel bro
really facts over feelings right y'all
facts over feelings so look what what
you bring if you if what you bring is
actual evidence I have to submit to it
if I'm honest okay it's not your whether
it's your opinion or my opinion if you
bring me evidence that Jesus believed in
what you just described as God then I
have to submit to it or I'm a dishonest
person all right let me repeat myself
then what's constitute an evidence for
you excellent good question so evidence
for me is early information about Jesus
about what he believed about how he
practiced his religion about what he
taught so if you can show me from the
you know historical evidence that what
Jesus believed and taught it lines up
with that God is not a father he's not a
mother he's not a trinity he's all by
himself right if you can show me all of
this that Jesus believed in this God me
my money then you get the money you win
show you yes I can't I was not around
that time right yeah but but don't we
have like writings we have his teachings
Jesus is a do you know writing can be do
you know writing can be
falsified okay
you know that right do you believe the
Quran is falsified it doesn't how would
I know I believe it's not you believe
it's not but you just you don't know for
sure how could I know I just believe a
belief is something you deep deep inside
know it's true without having any proof
right no see see see this see this this
is the thing with with what the Bible
teaches okay so what you just described
was blind faith believing in something
true in Your Heart Right without really
any solid evidence but you believe but
the Bible says this the Bible says that
faith is the substance of things hoped
for the evidence of Things Not Seen so
what faith in the Bible is is trusting
the evidence that's presented so I'm
choosing to trust the evidence that's
what true faith is according to the
Bible not Blind Faith so God invites you
to have true faith and not rest on Blind
Faith you can actually secure your
belief you can have a solid foundation
without saying you know I don't know
that's true but we were not talking
about that we were talking about if the
Quran was falsified right well so how
would I know that's right you're
changing like you're changing like the
topics I like your honesty so so this
what I'm so how let me let how do we
know anything about Jesus like where do
we get this information from where do
you get this information from you've
been giving me information all this time
where did you get it from
actually I got it from the
NG the the gospel oh the gospel mhm yeah
good for you yeah so the gospel is where
I learn about
Jesus for you are you a Muslim too all
right you'll be right after him okay oh
you with not good oh your Eng is not
good it's good enough I can hear
you I'mma leave you no don't leave yet
I'm leave why you haven't won the money
yet all right look look do you have the
money actually AB absolutely I just been
look I ain't going to show my money on
New York streets you know let
me show me just show me I can't do that
but look look this what I'll leave you
with okay so we get our information from
the gospel the NGO this is what we know
about Jesus what we see is that Jesus
claimed to be the Son of God okay so can
you post it right there
yeah who write the Gospel who who are
teaching the gospel
Jesus did you talk to him Jesus taught
the gospel I don't understand where did
you get that information from about
Jesus and you telling me the gospel from
his disciples from his companions oh
from these disciples I Witness
that's okay let him go don't distract it
but he got it no that's good that's
that's good he he says I Witnesses yeah
you know uh actually your eyes can
deceive you well they saw with their
eyes they touch with their hand they
hurt with their ears so so we have so we
have what we have brother what we have
what we have mhammad is 600 years later
trying to
describe of Christ so what we have guys
guys all right so what we're going to do
here I need you guys to keep it focused
okay I don't distract him so we have we
have the disciples we have the disciples
right they walked with Jesus they lived
with him so they tell us about him they
tell us they they they you know transmit
what he believed this is what we have of
him okay so what we learn is that he
spoke Aramaic he spoke Hebrew he spoke
Greek we see that he was a rabbi we see
that he Tau about the gospel the kingdom
of God we saw that he went against the
Pharisees and the Sadducees they had a
problem with them he claimed to be the
Messiah the Son of God these are all
these things that that he claimed so
this is what we find about in The Gospel
and we see what he believed that God was
his father okay hold on your friend has
a question go ahead who made the sin and
the moon Jesus Jesus how how can made
the sin and the moon before he come
because he's God before before he's God
the Creator and he decided to come and
take on flesh statue wait wait some some
man did why he can walk the statue
because they human men so who made the
sin I told you already God it Jesus Is
God who he can be a God the son he the
is here before him God no God he he he
was here before he was born before he
was born in human flesh he was here
existing sustaining all the universe
even when he was here on Earth he
sustained the universe where where where
did you see that in the in the Bible
see in the Quran is different no in the
Quran is the same in the Quran he's the
word of Allah right in the Quran he's
the word of Allah the word of Allah
created the heavens and the Earth the
Quran says that Jesus is his word so
that would mean that Jesus is the
Eternal Word of God who created all
things that would mean that Jesus is the
Eternal Word of Allah that created all
things the Quran says that the heavens
and the Earth was created by Allah's
word it says Jesus is Allah's word so
he's the creator of all things
I don't accept that yeah come on man how
you can say that because in the gospel
the gospel before Jesus we have Mo right
yes we have ibraim right yes what they
do what they believe what they bring
what they bring what they believe what
do they believe they believe that Jesus
they said Jesus yeah Jesus they they
said Jesus they believe that Jesus the
word of God Jesus they said Jesus they
said the word of they call they call him
the word of God go right they called him
the word of God where is Moes where is
Moses Moes yeah where is he yeah he's
with God right now he bore witness of
Christ on the mount with Elijah why he
go back to that's important point
because he was explaining his friends
who was him with him how is God how is
look like but how how does this say how
to do anything with Jesus being a Muslim
what how does this what does this have
to do with Jesus being a
Muslim Jesus is a prophet me it's a
prophet but he's more than that right
every Prophet is Muslim but he's also
Messiah right huh he's Messiah right
he's Messi Messiah Messi yeah Messi
means Christian no no not Messi messiah
messiah that Messi he is Christian mess
is
Messiah the Christ right the Christ
Theo all right so so this is where we're
at you're saying that Jesus is a prophet
you're saying all prophets are Muslim
right but like if you want to like for
example if you wanted to learn about
Moses if you wanted to see what he
taught right so where would you go to
see what Moses believed what he
taught uh the problem is my English is
not good but you use the Torah right the
Torah the book that Moses came with
right what would you what would you use
to read about it uh some had the Hadi
don't tell you about Moses man same same
same story no but dude they're getting
do you know where the people in the
Hadith are getting their information
from the people the the people in the
Hadith that's recording the when you say
Hadith that means they come with Prophet
or sahab you know yeah the companions
right sahab right do you know where the
sahaba are getting their information
about Moses from the pro muhamad no do
you know where Muhammad's getting it
from that's no he's getting it from the
Jews that are around him that are
telling him what the Torah says so he
used to sit and listen to the to the
Torah being recited by the Jews they
used to recite it and and tell it to
them in Arabic so so when they're when
they're learning about Moses they go to
the Torah the Quran said the Quran says
if you're in doubt Muhammad about what
we have revealed to you go and ask the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you what's his Quran yes what's
his Quran so the Quran is just a
recitation right supposedly a recitation
of Muhammad from Allah supposed to be
that if it's that if that's what it is
it also says it confirms the Torah that
came before and the gospel that came
before so if it did that we need to go
to the Torah and the gospel to learn
about the
prophets SMS good it's okay that's all
right man hey man give him a hand
man oh my God logic
n
[Music]